wait where's my phone oh yeah nothing
Gary's office by the way this is why I
love Instagram DM I saw a video that a
fan had made and I rehab them IBM got
them a message and they're like yeah
cool use it and so yo Andy you ready to
do your part
some vaynernation it's Andy brain
director for Gary Vaynerchuk you watch
it
yeah I'm watching it right now but what
do you think so far it's really good I
love the fact that he was talking about
office cuz that mindset is like the
mindset of a year yeah so we're trying
to come up with the best versions of de
vivir to post with Gary being off the
grid during the holidays we found this
motivational video from the Mulligan
brothers as a million views Wendy Rock
texted Gary he said I'm not gonna enjoy
it why don't you d rock and iris do it
so that's what we're doing my meditate
on it was that Gary's talking about
perspective and offense and everything
and that's exactly what these guys did
what like they just didn't have content
so they went out found it online cut it
up I got a million views out of it like
there's so much opportunity if your head
is in the right space to go and take it
I love like the key points of everything
and then adding on top of the music it's
it's good and then it has good b-roll in
it so excited for y'all to see it and it
just comes down to perspective and if
this video doesn't give you that
perspective you're [ __ ] out of luck
[Music]
I think so many people are keyboard
activists right everybody's good at
sending a tweet about how the world
should be and nobody's doing anything
about it and that just that is just very
much human nature we've gotten soft as a
culture yes you know I mean of course
we've gotten soft as a culture in the
u.s. because the US has had an
incredible two hundred year run right
like this is just what happens you know
so as a culture you know I can't speak
for you know people that live in the
Amazon River and I can't speak for you
know people that still live in Belarus
but the American culture is soft and
that's a great thing that means there's
been enormous amounts of prosperity but
let's not be naive
I mean people literally complain when
somebody gives them the wrong amount of
like extra cream in a Starbucks $6
coffee
[Music]
my lack of interest in complaining is so
high and when I watch what people
complain about it breaks my heart
because they completely lack perspective
and i genuinely believe my happiness and
optimism comes from my perspective even
in political unrest times like right now
a lot of people very bent out of shape
but the reality is is that it just never
been better to be a human being it's
that's just the truth that's just data
that's that's reality and yeah I mean
it's just a very fun time to be alive
and I think the way people look at the
world right now because it's such an
incredible time is actually the quickest
tell to who they are if you think it
sucks but it's bad
you have losing pessimistic DNA and if
you think it's awesome and phenomenal
you have optimistic winning DNA and I
believe that to be true and so that's
where rap we're beating ourselves up
like everybody sucks at something right
like we all have shortcomings and we all
have strengths and for me it's like why
don't we just audit that like why don't
we just look at it that way and be like
alright well I'm good at this but I'm
not good at that like and then and then
and then I only focus what I'm good at
right like I don't dwell that I can't
fix [ __ ] around the house I call
somebody to fix it like I'm not like I'm
not a man I don't give a [ __ ] like you
know like like you know like I don't I
don't get it like we all like I also
think it's awesome that I'm so
emotionally stable and I'm the emotional
backbone of everybody is that what a
dude's supposed to do like like these
cliches these stereotypes they're so
silly I'm fully in love with myself but
I'm also fully in love with everybody
else too right it's not like like it
goes both ways like I tell people to buy
into me that work for me it's cuz I buy
into them first like I don't need
anybody to gain trust with me I it's
there like I believe that the human race
is so grossly underrated we are good of
course we have some bad there's [ __ ]
7 billion of us but like when you look
at our net score it's bonkers [ __ ] like
you know what damage we can be doing to
each other on an hourly basis and we
don't like we're still here like we won
we're the alpha being and we've figured
out how to stay together this is insane
when you think about it and yet
everybody wants to dwell on like
somebody said something mean
if you want to be an anomaly you have to
act like one like people want all these
special things to happen but then
they're acting like everybody else and
that gets into this Saturdays on in your
20s like or or just like taking risks or
things of that nature like there's
anything they take away it's like look
like you're gonna only be so pretty
you're only gonna be so smart like you
like that there's there's things that
are gonna be natural and there's things
that you can actually control I do
believe and I don't know if I'm right or
wrong I don't but I do believe that work
ethic is a taught behavior it's
something you do have more control over
and you know what really sealed the deal
for me getting healthier I was 38 years
old and didn't come natural to me like
it didn't come natural to me at all I
hate the gym I hate him out I hate it I
don't like it I don't want to do it but
I but I knew it was important and
somewhere around
midway through being 38 years old I got
serious I figured out my system I made
the financial commitment and I've won
right and I'll never lose again because
the system was I needed to be
accountable to another human being so it
was about Mike and now Jordan and
whoever else is my trainer I'm doing it
almost weirdly more to not let them down
I feel like there's a shift that can
make people work harder the big one that
I push is you're gonna die like like if
your complaint like to me life is broken
down into complaining and not so if
you're not complaining well then I know
I have no advice for you but I'm pumped
like you did it like like I friends who
make $42,000 a year work 9:00 to 4:00
kind of with an hour to have lunch and
45 minutes of YouTube and ten minutes of
bullshitting and an hour of complete
waste of time in a meeting so the kind
of working like six you know hours a
week right but they're pumped and and
and they text me these are high school
friends and they'll text me like how
happy they are to be the culture their
kids baseball team and you know like
that's amazing but that seems very
obvious to me like that's like that's
right you know which is super weird I'm
actually nearly envious you know like I
it sounds cool
like in theory right grass is always
greener right like far less pressure you
know like like all that time with my
kids move that would be cool like
there's just like all these things that
I can justify so to me but I have
friends who have a hundred million
dollars in the bank because of
Facebook's IPO who complain who are
still hungry want to do even more
who will complain to me because they
know I work a lot about no work-life
balance and they don't get to spend
enough time with their family and I'm
like you have a hundred million dollars
like you could stay home like you're in
control like you don't complain about it
you've made that choice don't [ __ ]
me
like you want to spend more time with
your family spend more time with your
family
I'm trying to be very careful about what
I'm saying versus what I'm doing because
that's how you get exposed and I don't
mean like people calling you out and
being like you suck I mean to yourself I
don't want to be exposed by myself it's
it's it's looking at yourself in the
mirror and saying like am I doing this
right so to me there's so many people
they're talking [ __ ] about how big of an
entrepreneur they're gonna be and how
much they're gonna achieve and they
don't work on weekends you know I worked
every Saturday of my 20s like and I talk
to 20 year old entrepreneurs every
single day lately I've been saying to
them this Saturday you're gonna have
more time off than I've had in my entire
20s on a Saturday so like before you
tell me how you're gonna be bigger than
me start thinking about what you're
actually doing
[Music]
I'm careful to not give advice that I
know is uniquely something that I was
gifted with like I'd how do I tell you
that
oh here's how it actually works and it
almost started happening it didn't
happen like I actually get goosebumps
like actually like real heavy goosebumps
when I hear something that I know feels
right what's the advice there hey Johnny
start getting goosebumps like I can't
there's certain things that I can't talk
about because I know they're not
practical they're intuitive to me
I plan to instill kindness
elegance I plan on instilling
perspective into my kids I plan in
instilling just being a good human being
I plan on making sure they don't use
their parents wealth and micro Fame and
leverage to impose them on any other
person I was petrified of that if my
kids try to Punk their friends on my
[ __ ] I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of them
like that just loser DNA you didn't do
that we right like so like I'm not
obsessed with tactics I'm obsessed with
religion so I have a lot of wealthy
friends at this point who think it's
smart for them to sit first class but
the kids in coach it's a tactic they
send their kids to Africa to build a
school for a week it's a tactic it's
like my friends that love the
environment the number two sector in the
world that is hurting the environment is
the fashion industry when you run the
math of what's doing bad to the earth
it's the number two industry behind Gaza
I I don't even want to say because I'm
not sure if it's gas and oil the number
two industry the sign of the fact is the
fashion industry so all my fancy friends
who love the environment are they
willing to give up their [ __ ] louis
bags let's say right so like I think
people talk [ __ ] so you let them sit
coach and you went first class but you
went to you know Hawaii and eat it all
the best public you can't pick and
choose to me it's binary so I don't want
to be a hypocrite so my big thing is
like look you need to be kind like mean
mean is just non-negotiable in our
family right and then you just need to
not be full of [ __ ] if you want to look
at daddy's mountain and you want to say
what I did to my dad's and that was a
big mountain for an immigrant like Wow
dad did it right if you want to say I'm
gonna climb that and I'm gonna climb
bigger awesome like I'm pumped I'm
weirdly not cheering for you cuz I'm
I'm just a weirdly competitive dude this
is actually something I'm not proud of
I'm comfortable saying this and I
believe this as a flaw but I don't want
my kids to beat me I don't like I don't
I I hate saying it I know this is where
I get in trouble people take one little
clip from one video interview and
they're like you're a bad eye it's just
my truth I don't wanna [ __ ] you guys
like I'm that competitive
I just want them to be all in on them
right like I don't need them to be an
entrepreneur I don't need them to make
me proud they don't need to go to
Harvard they don't need to do [ __ ] they
need to be themselves all in and they
need to be kind and I'm good
like everybody thinks their stuff is so
good like everyday Gary my instagrams so
on fire soda awesome
why is nobody like why am I not gaining
followers because it's not awesome think
we all think our stuff is the best and
like I get that but yeah that would be
my advice only because that also is
liberating me everything's about
breathing right like to me everything is
about like take full ownership for
everything and then everything gets easy
because then you're in control and then
learn how to love to lose I think that's
how that's how entrepreneurship that's
how life is we all have losses and so I
like losses I love adversity I like the
climb I like the chip on my shoulder I
like when people like all I knew and
he's not that good that is like like I'm
even weirdly scared as I continue to
ascend and I'm getting popular and
wouldn't you say the marketing leaning
like if people start putting these words
in front of my name I'm like am I gonna
sabotage myself to like recorrect this
like I like adversity so yeah all on me
you know I enjoy losses now all of a
sudden like what you become completely
invincible I feel invincible I really
genuinely outside of the health of
myself and 20 people feel 100%
invincible as a person I know what my
intent is I want to do good at nobody
else's expense I'm far from perfect we
all are
and so just easy it feels very light to
live life I'm just in a good mood
[Music]
them home and I think modern-day parents
and most parents do not do that
I think they focus on dumb [ __ ] like
grades because they are insecure and
they want to put the bumper sticker that
their kid went to you know Stanford like
it's real [ __ ] up when you really
think about what's actually happening so
much of it is misery loves company or
people reflecting of what's inside of
them
[Music]
is the impact that you want to have on
the world
same thing that attracts so many of
millions of people to people that are
selling [ __ ] those same people are
attracted to me and what I want to do is
suffocate out all those other people and
become the Alpha of that entire world of
people that are are hoping and are
desperate to look at me and what I want
to do is inspire two 14 year old girls
in Kansas City right now to build a
billion dollar company on having a bunch
of employees hugging each other in the
halls I think that Steve Jobs came along
became an icon but the sad part of that
narrative was he did not treat his
employees well he became an icon and the
narrative became he got the most out of
people by being a jerk and that became
romanticized and a lot of people in
Silicon Valley today run companies
weren't they're mean because they think
that's the right thing to do because
they put Steve Jobs on a pedestal
I want my pedestal moment I want to
become that big and what I want to come
from that is that kids that aren't even
born today think that they can build a
five billion dollar company and be a
great guy or great gal I want to build
the biggest building in town ever by
just building the biggest building in
town while I think most people try to
tear down every
so I think positivity and good is
practical advice to building an empire
and I want to be the poster child and
the person that don't biggest baddest
empire and did it am I being a good dude
along the way and not everybody's gonna
be happy about everything I did but if
it's 97% of people talking good behind
your back that's a real legacy and I
want to do it in a pop culture way I'm
gonna do it anyway people have done that
before just so you know there's plenty
of people Warren Buffett's a really good
dude
like there's plenty of people that have
done that there's a difference I want to
do it and I want to be a rock star right
like and that's where you influence
people like you know like I want to do
it but I also want to be the most
popular and so then that person's like
oh I want to be him so I guess I'll be
nice like I want to literally take
people who have DNA that's kind of nice
and make them more nice because they
think that's how I became big so I
basically want to trick the business
world into becoming kinder
[Music]